all right thanks everybody for coming
out tonight usually in this class I like
to do lots of puzzles so if that's what
you're coming here for you'll be
slightly disappointed I do intend to
keep doing the puzzles but I thought you
know maybe I'll just take a little time
out to talk about a tournament that's
going on in Azerbaijan right now so in
shâm here we got the gas him off
Memorial Tournament that's been played
at the time of this recording we're five
rounds in and we're gonna be going over
some of the games of Fabiano Cara Wanda
who has four and a half out of five
points and a performance rating of close
to 3,100 so you know even even less
suspicious than some performances in
recent tournaments in the crowd but yeah
so he's playing a fantastic tournament
Giri also is really crushing it he's got
four out of five and okay we got two
games I just kind of want to show you of
his and I've I've met Fabiano what's
cool about my job is like I get to
actually meet all these players to come
to the club a super cool guy you know
he's very friendly
he'll just play anybody - I mean he
might come before the Sinquefield
company might play some games with just
random people so very nice guy he was
playing somebody else that I've also met
this was the round three game he was
playing how you fan and you fan also
super friendly person so these are our
two of the top friendliest people in the
world playing this game and Fabiano has
the white pieces and it was it was kind
of interesting the opening that we got
cozy fan hasn't been playing the really
Lopez as either side but against her
most recent World Women's World
Championship
she's been started to play it to be a
maryam Uzi trick so in that tournament
that helped you fan become the woman's
world champion she started playing -
Marie Lopez so perhaps Fabiano was ready
for this sort of thing might have been
part of his prep and we got an open
Royal Oh PES so all of this is it's very
typical
and in this position which has been seen
thousands of times a slightly less
common move here was played Knight B - D
- a little more popular c3 but this also
is a very interesting line that okay you
must know if you're you're playing this
especially at this level so I'm sure
this is part of both of their
preparation and okay it looks
interesting and now you play c3 and so
the first question I mean okay sheep
she played Bishop to e7 but a question
and I think maybe a lot of people have
is okay what can I just take this this
Bishop is this a bit strange the way
White's played this has he just given up
the bishops well this is actually known
to be pretty good for white this
variation the problem is we have a
knight going to d4 in these lines so
even after a move like Bishop e7 you can
even play the knight from F to d4 would
anybody like to take this pond somebody
would yeah somebody wants the pawn in
this variation after rook e1 black can
get into a little bit of trouble you
know something like this and now even
stronger than taking on e6 is Knight to
d4 and the knight goes to e6 even if you
play e5 the knight still goes to e6 and
this is just good news for white okay so
what they they really end up playing is
they take here and just to give you an
idea so this wasn't played in the game
but okay if you just castle for example
we get our our bishop here and okay
we're gonna get a lot of active pieces
on the Queen side so oh this should be
be quite good for white you can
conversely also try to play a 5 which
prevents some of those ideas because
yeah if you just play Bishop d2 now I'm
playing a 4 so you can play here you're
gonna put the knight on c5 and you want
to take back with a piece not a pond and
black can prepare Bishop to f5 okay so
you get some some position like this
where again the night jumps in and okay
white just has good control over the
queenside
and you know should have some good play
over on that the kingside whenever he's
ready so something like this is is not
in blacks best interest which is why in
this position okay she left the bishop
alone she's gone on with developing and
Bishop to see to okay so again this has
just been played so many times
d4 Bishop g4 also is very popular move
well will focus you're on the main line
the game of the game line at least so
Knight to b3 I would like to take on d4
so black takes sorry after d3 white you
can you can play this line but a lot of
stuff gets traded so it's not the best
way for white to try for an advantage so
Fabiano keeps the piece on the board and
now we we get this trade and this is
okay well we're going to go a little bit
faster this opening here he played
rookie one more popular is Bishop to e3
this is the maneuver white is gonna do
in this game so that he can isolate the
the D pawn and he's just he's gonna try
to get the pawn back but okay he started
with rook e1 not bad and we get this
position and this has been reached quite
a few times in here
he had a novelty prepared so this is
still all his prep and the most
impressive thing at least to me about
Fabiano is just how well-prepared he is
the Ziegfeld Cup when he was here and he
went seven and no it seemed like every
game he had some novelty with some you
know really powerful idea behind it and
it was never really obvious but then
okay after you see the game you're like
wow that was really a fantastic move
great idea and you just continue to do
that like every game us championship was
the same way he out prepped so many
opponents he's I mean he just knows so
many lines and so many openings really
really hard to tell prepare this guy I
mean he's most prepared man in the world
of chess so and here he had something in
mind so white played a novelty normally
rookie three is played and you
just you go get the pond and that's fine
I mean white she'll get a slight
advantage in those lines but he played
this very very interesting move
h4 what's that all about well it seems
like nowadays everybody in every opening
they play h4 h5 h6 but there is there is
a little points and it actually took me
a while I was trying to think about what
look at the point possibly be here of
this move and I suspect that is it point
is if you take here with the night just
seems seems normal enough and now I take
back you no longer can just drop your
Bishop back because h5 traps your piece
you know something like this because
also you might be wondering - ok but
what if we we go here and this is the
same in the line where if ok if I play
h5 then you get to come back here and
then Queen to g4 is a pretty good move
that should be be decent for what wait
though it does get a little bit
complicated because now in some lines
you're playing right here for example if
you go back and I play here you know
things are getting a little bit
complicated and I'm gonna go back and
you know then you can trade and whatever
but what's interesting too is ok you
didn't even just play a move like this
and this is not a threat so we'll get
the audience involved there's a couple
good moves here for white but what would
you guys play
and obviously if your opponent lets you
just take on g2 you should be a little
suspicious there might be there might be
a trick here and so here the yeah Queen
takes d3 is that the simplest so you're
threatening to take and deliver me so if
you don't get mated I go here in your
bishops trapped so a very interesting
feature in this position and so okay so
h4 that's perhaps part of it it's just
trying to prevent you from taking on d4
very interesting idea and he or she she
really thought for a long time she does
have some other options in the game she
played Bishop to g6 but okay also
interesting it's playing the immediate
d2 and I can safely play Queen takes d2
or I can even think of giving up an
exchange here this also seems very
interesting and you can prevent me from
playing before and okay I do have sort
of an initiative on the Kings side as
white but you know you got an exchange
as black so this also would have been
interesting I wonder if he was just
gonna take on d2 or if he was gonna sack
the exchange here but in the game she
thought for nearly half an hour and she
played Bishop to g6 and it's not
immediately obvious that this should be
such a bad move
but you are giving up control over East
six so in a lot of lines why just trying
to play e6 and so here a very very
tricky move B for perhaps I'm just
clamping down on the queenside or
perhaps I have a little trick
does anyone see what is weight
threatening in this position Bishop - a
- yeah this is a big threat and your
Queen moves away and I play e6 yeah you
can't you can't let me do that so you
have sort of two options in the game she
played d2 the point is you attack the
rook and then you're gonna trade the
bishops not any better is taking here
but this is also a playable line and we
take back and now if here we get a
position that's similar to the game I
might play e6 I might play Knight f5
we'll just you know in the future so
these moves are one of these two moves
are coming up and this should be quite
pleasant for for white I mean I have to
move my Queen first before I move my
knight but it's an idea in the position
and probably six is coming very quickly
so instead in the game d2 was played
okay and the point was to trade the
bishop
and she had a little tactic here so she
was also kind of counting on this this
tactical move
Bishop takes before
and okay it's really ill-advised to take
this bishop this looks pretty bad
because if you're allowing these trades
and okay now I should probably move my
queen
- like f4 or something but if you I mean
you play an endgame like this it's just
gonna be really good for Black was a lot
of pressure in this position so okay
he's not interested in just taking the
bishop so cleanup for in this h4 move it
might be useful in an attack wide is
starting to get his pieces over there
you know so black has to be really
careful and that's where White's
advantage in this position is he has
he's getting a King side attack going
okay the bishop was attacked so it moved
and let's see if you guys can play like
Fabiano here a very nice move was played
so this is a good puzzle you may want to
pause your video see what a see if you
guys can figure it out at home in this
position we played a six and you know
sort of the move that you you are trying
to play in this types of position so
it's worth seeing if you can make it
work tactically so black took and do we
see the point
I want to get a night online 3545 mm-hmm
yeah 95 my guys whom the just tonight
will take and also I can always play
like work that fade if I I really need
to defend all right so here is so here
queen g4 this was the idea
all right threatening me is it's pretty
good
and yeah so g6 is actually it's it's the
computer kind wants to play g6 but it
looks a little scary you know this looks
I mean because at some point I'm playing
h5 I mean I can I don't know it looks it
looks kind of scary but perhaps you can
get away with it it's not it's not the
human reaction I don't think to the
problems here in the game
then we took on d4 there's some other
options too bishop f8 and when I one
option that I think also is of interest
is the move e5 the point is to trade
some stuff so if Bishop takes okay the
knight takes and we take back you get a
position like this which is clearly
better for white but you know compared
to the game I think this would be the
much preferable option okay obviously
there was a few options to consider
people are looking like what trade
everything we're on the e-file
so you wanna play here immediately okay
yeah so maybe maybe Queenie four okay
yeah so I'm here and you have your trade
will okay yeah so I mean I don't have to
trade the computer if I remember I
wanted to go here
just get some some counter threats on f2
but after you know one of the rooks - II
- its it should be better for white you
know something like like like something
like this it should be slightly better
for white with with this coming pretty
soon yeah in the game yet then I took on
d4 but this has its own problems because
now I take on d4 and the Knights go into
e6
this is impossible because we go here
we're taking everything so if here okay
I mean at minimum we can we can take on
c7
or take the rope you know either way
okay so Bishop f6 and okay black will
happily take the knight because now the
knight just jumping into e6 and there's
lots of threats we're attacking all
sorts of stuff here and you have to play
the right move here as black but we can
blender for a second because that's
that's kind of fun we'll just move the
rook will protect the pond
does anyone see what White's threat is
in this position yeah a knight takes g7
all right good good engine analysis and
okay if you take back do we do we see
the follow-up here yeah I take yeah
what's come out those say yeah rookie 7
yeah and yeah and good look stopping my
threat you're gonna have to play like
Queen f7 or something okay so rook d7
you know so we're protecting all of the
stuff here and he just improves his
pieces he can double on the e-file at
some point the rook can swing over to g3
it's not it's not very easy to play
black so she tried h5 she was trying to
prevent white from playing h5 h6 but
this does weaken the Kings side so okay
that the Queen got a little bit closer
and here there's nothing for her to
really do and so white gets the pieces
in and and black is sort of out of
options
so here already the position is winning
for white
okay there's there's many ways to win he
chose the night F for it is interesting
though to point out this move that is a
little bit stronger rook d3 with the
point of kicking the Queen off of the D
file and only then playing work f3
threatening to take the bishop and yeah
if the Queen we're still in the D file
she could go to like d2 and cause a few
disturbances but okay he can win however
he wants this also was is very good I
took with the Queen now Knight to g6 is
coming yes it's just this is really bad
rook f7 I mean no better is is the trade
here we take on f6 and then we take and
the rook goes to g3 so she she kept the
rook on the board and here again Knight
takes f6 would have been a really strong
move because there's not a good way to
take back but rook d1 still winning
and then yeah this just ended the game
so she resigned right here yeah the
point is yeah and we take this thing so
again it was just an example of Cara
wanna with fantastic preparation you
know he had that h4 move in mind and you
know just straight away straight when
she had to start thinking for the first
time she made a mistake and it wasn't
you know so easy to sort out the
complications and he was able to get a
good position out of the opening and and
then he just went on to win a very nice
attacking game
and we'll show one more game tonight
this was the fifth round game so the the
most recent here and this in his game
against timur raja baath who was having
a medium medium tournament yeah how do
you find and Reggie Bob just haven't
really got got started yet but both of
their schedules are a little bit easier
in the second half of the tournament
whether they don't have to play Fabiano
anymore so that okay so he's playing
Rancher Bob here and he doesn't usually
go in for the open Sicilian that's not
really a style he likes to play the
Rosalie mow play a little more
positionally which is good it's what I
kind of like about Caruana style is he
always plays for a really small
advantage which in general the best way
to try to get a big advantage in chess
is to play for a small advantage it
seems like he always gets some very
slight advantage he's in the u.s.
championship it's like okay you're
playing some 2600 you're only a little
bit better but then you know then he
wins like every game so sometimes it's
you know okay some endgame it's very
close to equal you just got a little
something and then he makes something
out of it he's very good at that as
super grandmasters tend to do alright
there's many move orders here but okay
g6 was played castles is a move but okay
he took the night he plays this
variation and we get a typical enough
line h3 is played one of the things for
black in this position is how are you
going to develop this bishop so h3 just
prevents Bishop g4
late to c3 any castles
and now he played already an interesting
move that's not very popular but perhaps
this was all all this preparation again
Bishop to f4 by far the most common move
here is Bishop to e3 and when you you
protect here if you play Queen d2 the
main move here for black is to play the
movie five dropping upon no no but then
black can take here in this this is good
for black but okay white has time he
plays Bishop to h6 and castles Queen
side well that's worth noting so we can
understand why this move was played he's
just preventing 85 so one of the
differences he still has the same plan
Queen d2 probably castling queenside but
here since black hasn't played e5 yet he
has one move and he can play rook to e8
with the idea that whenever you play
Bishop h6 we can drop our Bishop back so
we don't have to trade fair enough all
right and he cancelled and so now yeah
we're gonna get an interesting game
we've got opposite side castling who's
gonna get a bigger attack here and so
here comes black
you know an interesting move too you
might think okay maybe it was the bishop
that's going to e5 but he actually went
with the knight attacking c6
in black said you can have it if you
want it
so we'll pause here in lastik class what
would you guys play as white you take
the pawn when you play another move yeah
nobody knows too hard yeah yeah so if
Reggie Bob plays this you know it's a
trick but if anybody else plays it when
dannis LaRue plays it he's dropping upon
it he didn't take this actually is quite
dangerous it really accelerates blacks
attack the pawn isn't so important it's
it's you know it's sort of a useless
pawn and okay now he it gets to
accelerate his attack a4 he plays b5
next so whatever you do b5 which yes
gives you the c-4 square so then I can
come back and then you can move your
other night away but blacks attack here
is already quite quick and white is
nowhere near attacking the black King so
he did not wish to do this instead a
very interesting move Queen e3 going
after the C pond and when black defends
both pawns something very unusual will
happen with the the Queen's on the same
diagonal here so stay tuned
yes something very interesting is going
to happen at least something quite
fantastic okay
and okay the point of rookie eight was
that we were going to train them and now
white gets going with his kingside play
alright and here comes black
and weight improves his rook
and now here perhaps the best move would
be just to try to get rid of the
annoying knight on e5 something like
this trade these guys off and if I play
e5 maybe I'm gonna play 94 next but you
can play f5 I don't want to take on
pissant and liberate your broken Bishop
so something like this could have been
played but instead we got to move Issa
'xs
you have some audience members get a get
a sour face but that's that's what he
played g4 and again you can play 97 you
can play b4 but he played a3 and this is
the move that really stood out when I
first saw this game so this move here is
fantastic so yeah you should pause your
your video at home then we'll see if the
the audience here can see what a what if
Fabiano play in this position yeah stood
out before I looked it looked at the
game
b3 even with the b4 joke you you still
claim b3 yeah
b4 Wow yeah fantastic stuff you normally
when you're getting attacked you don't
move your pond two squares in front of
your king
yeah p3 also is okay for white but now
you're gonna win a pond
okay so he does get rid of this this
night here be careful cuz your knight on
c3 is hanging so e5 alright if you do
nothing then I go I go in here and do
stuff so f5 again there's there's no
temptation to even take on pass on here
you're a little tempted just cuz you're
like maybe they don't know the UM
passant rule yeah
and now okay it's it's White's turn so I
guess what would you guys do here so
again it's we can take the pawn two
different ways we can try to play
something else a lot of possibilities
and the good news for you guys is
basically every move was fine for way
those positioned so you can take either
way or do something else in the game he
decided to play 92 a very safe decision
we can have a quick look at what happens
if you take which should work out in
White's favor but it does allow black
counter play
let's take with the Queen first and in a
position like this you know you might
notice he's getting a little active here
and you can imagine this bishop
rerouting getting some activity okay
maybe not what you want but you are up
upon so the computers happy plus-one
you're up upon so that's it is possible
so it's not not a huge mistake at least
objectively but okay and something like
this too you know he might get some
counter play you always have to be
worried about this now it's all sorts of
stuff like this he didn't see any reason
and okay maybe I'll take it later so 92
and so here I think black was was
sensing that he could be a little bit of
trouble so he tries to trade some pieces
yeah obviously that that will weaken the
dark squares so he happily took and it's
kind of funny because it's the attack
that black hat is just sort of
completely stalled the move b4 has sort
of stopped all of his play and now it's
whites turn h4
yeah I'm playing h5
yeah this is uh not the best piece and
uh okay I mean it's at the moment maybe
you're thinking okay you're not so great
but wait about two moves
yeah all right black took sure no h5
so if you don't do something about it
I'm gonna open the H file and I'm gonna
get my rook here and this is gonna go
here and my Queens gonna go somewhere in
here and my Knights gonna go do stuff so
he took mostly to keep the H file closed
at least for the moment and now okay
there's there's a lot of good moves here
Knight to g3 is one of them I'm just
gonna go take the pawn and there's
nothing you can really do about it if
you play a move like h4 which seems
tempting right keep the pond yeah Knight
h5 check and when the night comes in to
f6 you're in a little bit of trouble
among other moves that we can play he's
totally crushing now okay you can you
can start attacking stuff and this is
happening and the Queen's coming in and
I'm taking all your pawns and so this is
bad news but it's it is kind of similar
to the game in the game he just decided
to get the King out of the way
immediately sensible enough but the
knight still comes to f6 and so I mean
white is just completely winning in this
position all right and the night goes to
f6 there's a lot of good moves here rook
to h1 wins very convincingly okay but he
he tried f5 also very good so now yeah
the Queen's coming over to the H file
the rooks coming over he took and again
you know Brooke h1 is great but he takes
with this rook so he can get his other
rook over to the H file that's that's a
fast way to W to go here or I'll go here
okay don't you threaten the pond and
wait also makes a threat let's uh let's
see if the audience is still awake yeah
yeah it's a small threat okay so he
moved this bishop will just rook also
interesting is is this move and the only
reason to show it is because the
computer line is great
so when you're and when you're analyzing
a game like this and you see the line
that's so fantastic as this must be
shown in this position there's okay
everything waited you take on h7 you win
either way it doesn't matter but Queen
h6 yeah I mean yeah and yeah when you
take yeah and you pick up this Queen
okay so there's a lot of fantastic ways
for black to go wrong he he chose not to
go wrong
darn because that would have been Queen
h6 would have been a really nice way to
to play in the game okay bad stuffs
happening and now he plays here
in the game he took on g4 which I mean
white weights still winning here but I
mean it's also quite possible just to
take here and make sure black never does
anything bad to you but okay he chose to
take and well I should probably take the
opportunity to take on b4 but ok a
little bit worried about his king he
plays Queen no 7
he is attacking the a2 pond
so he played the circumspect move king
b1 just protecting the pawn very safe
but it is quite possible just to ignore
the threat black really isn't
threatening that much if the Queen goes
too far away from the king white is
gonna have some stuff that the check
means nothing the white there's a lot of
threats here like rook takes Bishop okay
but he played the safe way make sense
and now that that ponds gone Queen d4
which is gonna set up for this this next
move here okay so black wants to trade
pieces this much is obvious
eise --ax yeah I found that that rather
easily
yeah e6 a fantastic move yeah excellent
way to to finish off the game in the
game he took the rook but we can lose
two other ways we can we can take this
thing if here tell you another best move
now yeah and if you take check and if
here we would like to play this move but
then he plays here and okay we can play
rook h4 but but how do we check mate
black
Queen h1 yes as I was saying Queen h1
allows you to play here and yeah you can
play here in this this one's for white
but we can we can check me yeah yeah
Queen e3 alright so if you go to h5 then
Queen g5 and if here and you you can you
can do that okay so alright that move is
out this this move also is not very good
here we can even take with our Knight
so the rook is pinned so if we you know
just play a bad move okay we can we can
move away in this jack and okay bad bad
stuffs happening you're just about to
get made it here so okay for those
reasons after the movie six very nice
move rook takes g4 yeah everything
everything is waiting for white but it's
a very nice finish to a very nice game
yes yeah yeah
because you saw the game yeah that's a
good reason to play that move right
exactly all right ridiculous and you'll
have phones you're not even looking it
up as we're going along being brilliant
yeah this was an excellent idea so I'm
I'm promoting with checkmate and yeah
yeah I can't play here let's all right
is that loud enough for Bensimon though
I don't know where he went but he really
likes to hear it okay so well yeah just
some truly fantastic games here by Cara
Juana
he came in with sort of not the most
popular opening so there wasn't a whole
lot of theory but he had an idea he was
preventing e5 rate from the start and
when it it became attacking on both
sides he found the move b4 which was
fantastic and then later on e6 just
another brilliant move to a truly nice
and beautiful game that he played right
here so you can see why he he does
pretty well in tournaments he gets
little advantages and then suddenly
turns out he's also pretty good at
tactics so fantastic play by him
hopefully you guys enjoyed those games
actually I do it is on here yeah cuz
there was a another chess base file
named Cara Juana and so I opened it up
and it's all fine go for Carmona so I
didn't name my might thing something
else so I do have that game yeah okay
yeah so if you guys enjoyed this go
ahead and hit a like share subscribe
thanks everybody